this is dollar bag it's a neighborhood
in a small town very near Amsterdam in
the Netherlands there are 27 houses for
6-7 people each there's a small mall
with a restaurant a pub a supermarket
the club room there are streets alleys
there's a theatre
it actually is a nursing home a nursing
home for people that live with an
advanced dementia and that me 24/7 care
and support
dementia is a terrible disease and we
still don't have any cure for it it's
getting to be a major problem in the
world for the people for the politicians
for the world it's getting to be a big
problem we see that we have waiting
lists in the nursing homes most people
that come to the nursing house with
dementia are women and that's also
because
women are used to taking care of people
so they can manage to take care of their
husbands with dementia but the other way
around is not so easy for the gentleman
dementia is a disease that affects the
brain the brain is confused people don't
know anymore what the time is what's
going on who people are they're very
confused and because of that confusion
they get to be
anxious depressed
aggressive
this is a traditional nursing home I
worked there in 1992 I was a care
manager and we often spoke together
about the fact that what we were doing
there was not what we wanted for our
parents for our friends for ourselves
and one day we said when we keep on
saying this nothing is going to change
we are in charge here we should do
something about it so that we do want to
have our pair here we talked about that
and what we saw every day was that the
people that lived in our nursing home
were confused about their environment
because what they saw was a hospital
like environment with doctors and nurses
and paramedics in uniform and they lived
on a ward and they didn't understand why
they lived there and they looked for the
place to get away they looked and hoped
to find the door to go home again and we
said what we are doing in this situation
is offering these people that already
have a confused brain
some more confusion we were adding
confusion to confusion and that was not
what these people needed these people
wanted to have a life and the help our
help to deal with that dementia these
people wanted to live in a normal house
not in a ward they wanted to have a
normal household where they would smell
their dinner on the stove in the kitchen
or happy free to go to the kitchen and
grab something to eat or drink that's
what these people need it and that's
what we should organize for them and we
said we should organize this like at
home so they wouldn't live with a group
of 15 or 20 or 30 like an award now a
small group of people six or seven
family like
like living with friends
and we should find a way to select
people based on their ideas about life
so that they did have a good chance to
become friends when they live together
and we interviewed all the families of
the residents about what is important
for your father what's important for
your mother what is their life like what
what do they want and we found seven
groups and we call them life style
groups and for instance we found this
formal life style in this life now
people have a more formal way of
interacting with each other distant way
their daily rhythm starts later in the
day ends later in the day classical
music is more heard in this lifestyle
grouping and other lifestyle groups and
their menu well is more French cuisine
than traditional Dutch
in contrary to the Craftsman lifestyle
that's a very traditional lifestyle and
they get up early in the morning go to
bed early because they have worked hard
their whole life mostly with their hands
very often had a very small family
business a small farm a shop or like mr.
B he was a farmhand and he told me that
he would go to his work every morning
with a paper bag with his lunch and one
cigar
that one cigar was the only luxury he
could afford for himself and after lunch
he would have that one cigar and
until the day he died in the home egg he
was in this little shed every day after
lunch to smoke his cigar
this is my mother she's of the cultural
lifestyle she's been living in the whole
quick six weeks now and
that lifestyle is about traveling
meeting other people other cultures
interest in arts and music there are
more lifestyles
but that's what we talked about and
that's what we did
but that's not life in a house with a
group of people like-minded people your
own life your own household there's more
in life everybody wants fun in life in a
meaningful life we are social animals we
need a social life and that's what we
started
we want to go out our house and do some
shopping and meet other people or go to
the pub have a beer with friends or like
mr. W he likes to go out every day see
if there are nice ladies around
and he's very courteous to them and he
hopes for smiles and he gets them and he
bounces with them in the pub it's a
feast every day there are people that
would rather go to the restaurant have a
wine with friends or lunch with it or
dinner with friends and celebrate life
and my mother she makes a walk in the
park and sits on a bench in the Sun
hoping that a passerby will come and sit
next to her and have a conversation
about life or about the columns in the
ducks in the pond that social life is
important it means that you're a part of
society that you belong and that's what
we people need
even if you are living with an advanced
dementia
this is what I see from my office window
and one day I saw a lady coming from one
side and the other lady from the other
side and they met at the corner and I
knew both ladies very well I often saw
them walking around outside and now and
then I tried to have a conversation with
them but their conversation was
rather hard to understand and
but I saw them meeting and I saw them
talking and I saw them gesturing and
they had fun together and then they said
goodbye and each went their own way and
that's what you want in life meeting
other people and being part of society
and that's what I saw happening
the whole quebec has become a place
where people within the very advanced
dementia can live have freedom and
safety because the professionals working
there and the volunteers working there
know how to deal with dementia and the
professionals know how to do their
professional work in a way that it fits
in a natural way in the life of our
residents and
that means that the management has to
provide everything those people need to
do their work it needs a management that
dare to do this to do things differently
than what we always have done in the
traditional nursing home
we see that it works
we think this can be done everywhere
because this is not for the rich we've
been doing this with the same budget as
any traditional nursing home has in our
country we work only with state budget
[Music]
because it has to do with thinking
difference and looking at that person in
front of you and looking at what does
this person need now and it's about a
smile it's about thinking different it's
about how you act and that costs nothing
and
there's something else it's about making
choices
it's about making choices what you spend
your money on I
always say
red curtains are as expensive as gray
ones
it's possible everywhere
thank you
[Applause]